welcome freako campers to a practical
introduction to natural language
processing with tensorflow - I am your
host dr. Phil Taber in 2012 I got my PhD
in experimental condensed matter physics
and went to work for Intel Corporation
as a back-end dryads process engineer I
let there in 2015 to pursue my own
interests and have been studying
artificial intelligence and deep
learning
ever since if you're unfamiliar with
natural language processing it is the
application of deep neural networks to
text processing it allows us to do
things such as text generation you may
have heard the hubbub in recent months
over the open AIG pt2 algorithm that
allow them to produce fake news it also
allows us to do things like sentiment
classification as well as something more
mathematical which is representing
strings of characters words as
mathematical constructs that allow us to
determine relationships between those
words but more on that in the videos it
would be most helpful if you have some
background in deep learning if you know
something about deep neural networks but
it's not really required we're gonna
walk through everything in the tutorial
so you'll be able to go from start to
finish
without any prior knowledge although of
course it would be helpful if you would
like to see more deep learning
reinforcement learning and natural
language processing content check me out
here on YouTube ad machine learning with
Phil I hope to see you there and I
really hope you enjoy the video let's
get to it
in this tutorial you are gonna learn how
to do word embeddings with tensorflow
2.0 if you don't know what that means
don't worry I'm gonna explain what it is
and why it's important as we go along
let's get started
before we begin with our imports a
couple of housekeeping items first of
all I am basically working through the
tensorflow tutorial from their website
so I'm gonna link that in the
description so I'm not claiming this
code is my own although I do some
cleaning up at the end to kind of make
it my own
but in general it's not really my code
so we start with our imports as usual we
need I Oh to handle dumping the word
embeddings to a file so that we can
visualize later we'll need matplotlib to
handle plotting we will need tensorflow
as TF and just a word so this is
tensorflow 2.10 RSC one release
candidate one so this is as far as I'm
aware the latest build so tensorflow 2.0
throw some really weird warnings and 2.1
seems to deal with that so I've upgraded
so if you're running tensorflow 2.0 and
you get funny errors i sorry funny
warnings but you still get functional
code and learning that is why you want
to update to the newest version of
tensorflow of course we need chaos to
handle pretty much everything we also
need the layers for our embedding and
dense layers and we're also going to use
the tensor flow datasets so I'm not
going to have you download your own data
set we're going to use the IMDB movie
data set for this particular tutorial
so of course that is an additional in
dependency for this tutorial so now that
we've handled our imports let's talk a
little bit about what word embeddings
are so how can you represent a word for
a machine and more importantly instead
of a string of characters how can you
represent a collection of words a bag of
words if you will so you have a number
of options one way is to take the entire
set of all the words that you have in
your say movie reviews you know you just
take all the words and find all the
unique words and that becomes your
dictionary and you can represent that as
a one hot encoding so if you have let's
say 10,000 words then you would have a
vector for each word with 10,000
elements which are predominant zeroes
except for the one corresponding to
whichever word it is the problem with
this encoding is that while it does work
it is incredibly inefficient and because
it is sparse you know the majority of
the data is 0 and the only one important
bit and the whole thing so not very
efficient and another option is to do
integer encoding so you can just rank
order the numbers sorry the words you
could do it in alphabetical order the
order doesn't really matter you can just
assign a number to each unique word and
then every time that word appears in a
review you would have that integer in an
array so you end up with a set of
variable length of rays where the length
of the array corresponds to the number
of words in the review and the members
of the array correspond to the words
that appear within that review now this
works this is far more efficient but
it's still not quite ideal right so it
doesn't tell you anything about the
relationships between the words so if
you think of the word let's say King it
has a number of connotations right a
king is a man for one so there's some
relationship between a king and a man a
king has power right has control over a
domain a kingdom so there is also the
connotation of owning land and having
control over that land King males have a
queen so it has some sort of
relationship to a queen as well I may
have a prince a princess you know all
these kinds of different relationships
between words that are not incorporated
into the an integer encoding of our
dictionary the reason is that the
integer encoding of our dictionary forms
a basis in some higher dimensional space
but all those vectors are orthogonal so
we take their dot product they are
essentially at right angles to each
other in a hybrid dimensional space and
so their dot product is zero so there's
no projection of one vector one word
onto another there's no overlap in the
meaning between the words at least in
this higher dimensional space
now word embeddings fix this problem by
keeping the integer encoding but then
doing a transformation to a totally
different space so we introduce a new
space of a vector of some arbitrary
length it's a hyper parameter of your
model much like the number of neurons in
a dense layer as a hybrid parameter of
your model the length of the embedding
layer is a hyper parameter and we'll
just say it's eight so the word King
then has eight floating-point elements
that describe its relationship to all
the other vectors in that space and so
what that allows you to do is to take
dot products between two arbitrary words
in your dictionary and you get nonzero
components and so that what that means
in practical terms is that you get a
sort of semantic relationship between
words that emerges as a consequence of
training your model so the way it works
in practice is we're gonna have a whole
bunch of reviews from the IMDB data set
and they will have some classification
as a good or bad review so for instance
you know for the Star Wars last Jedi
movie I don't think it's in the in there
but you know my review would be that it
was terrible awful no good totally
ruined Luke Luke's character and so you
would see and I'm not alone in that so
if you did a huge number of reviews for
the last Jedi you would see a strong
correlation of words such as horrible
bad wooden characters MarySue things
like that and so the model would then
take those words run them through the
embedding layer and try to come up with
a prediction for whether or not that is
a good or bad review and match it up to
the training label and then do back
propagation to vary those weights in
that embedding layer so say eight
elements and by training over the data
set multiple times you can refine these
weights such that you are able to
predict whether or not a review is
positive or negative about a particular
movie but also it shows you the
relationship between the words because
the model learns the correlations
between words within reviews that give
it either a positive or negative
context so that is word embeddings in a
nutshell and we're going to go ahead and
get started coding that so the first
thing we're gonna have is a an embedding
layer and this is just gonna be for
illustration purposes and that'll be
layer is embedding and let's say there's
a thousand and five elements so we'll
say result equals embedding layer TF
constant one two three so then let's
print the result dot numpy okay so let's
head to the terminal and execute this
and see precisely what we get actually
let's do this to print result dot numpy
that shape I think that should work
let's see what do we get in the terminal
and let's head to the terminal now all
right let's give it a try okay so what's
important here is you see that you get
an array of three elements right because
we did the TF constant of one two and
three and you see we have five elements
because we have broken the integers into
some components in that five element
space okay so and it has shaped three by
five which you would expect because
you're passing on three elements in each
of these three elements these three
integers correspond to a word of an
embedding layer of five elements okay
that's relatively clear let's go back to
the code editor and see what else we can
build with this okay so let's go ahead
and just kind of comment out all this
stuff because we don't need it anymore
so now let's get to the business of
actually loading our data set and doing
interesting things with it so we want to
use the data set load function so we'll
say train data
test data and some info t FDS download
IMDB reviews if s slash sub words 8 okay
and then we will define a split and that
as T FDS split train TFTs split dot test
and we will have a couple other
parameters with info equals true then
incorporates information about the about
the data set and as supervised equals
true so as supervised tells the data set
loader that we want to get back
information in the form of data and
label as a tuple so we have the labels
for training of our data so now we're
going to need an encoder so we'll say
info dot features text dot encoder and
so let's just find out what words we
have in our dictionary from this we'll
say print encoder and sub words first
twenty elements save that and head back
to the terminal and print it out and see
what we can see so let's run that again
and you it's hard to see let me move my
face
over for a moment and you can see that
we get a list of words the underscore so
the underscore corresponds to a space
you get commas periods a underscore and
underscore of so you have a whole bunch
of words with underscores that indicate
that they are spaces okay so this is
kind of the makings of a dictionary so
let's head back to the code editor and
continue building on this so we no
longer need that print statement now the
next problem we have to deal with is the
fact that these reviews are all
different lengths right so we don't have
an identical length through each other
reviews and so when we load up elements
into a matrix let's say they're gonna
have different lengths and that is kind
of problematic so the way we deal with
that is by adding padding so we find the
length of the longest review and then
for every review that is short in that
we append a bunch of zeroes to the end
in our bag of words so a list of words
you know the list of integers we will
append a bunch of zeroes at the end so
zero isn't a word it doesn't correspond
to anything in the words start with one
the rank ordinal numbers start with one
and so we insert a zero because it
doesn't correspond to anything it won't
hurt the training of our model so we
need something called padded shapes and
that has this shape so batch size and an
empty list an empty tuple there so now
that we have our padded shapes we're
ready to go ahead and get our training
and test batches so let's do that
and since we are good data scientists we
want to do a shuffle we're gonna use a
batch size of 10 and they padded shapes
specified by what we just defined let's
clean that up
and let's copy because the Train the
test batches are pretty much identical
except it's test data duffel and it's
the same size so we don't have to do any
changes there scroll down so you can see
okay so that gives us our data so what
we need next after the data is an actual
model so let's go ahead and define a
model so in as is typical for Karis it
is a sequential model and that takes a
list of layers so the first layer is an
embedding layer and that takes encoder
vocab size now this is you know given to
us up here by the encoder object that's
given by the information from our data
set and we have some vocabulary size so
there's 10,000 words vocabulary size is
vocab size it's just the size of our
dictionary and we want to define an
embedding DIMM so that's the number of
dimensions for our embedding layer so
we'll call it something like 16 to start
so let's add another layer global gobble
global average pulling 1d and then we'll
need a finally a dense layer 1 output
activation equals sigmoid so it this
seems mysterious what this is is the
probability that a mapping of sorry this
layer is the probability that the review
is positive so it's a sigmoid go ahead
and get rid of that and now we want to
compile our model with the Adam
optimizer a binary cross entropy loss
with accuracy metrics not meatrix
metrics equals accuracy ok that's our
model and that is all we need for that
so now we are ready to think about
training it so let's go ahead and do
that next so what we want to do is train
and dump the history of our training and
an object called that we're going to
call history model that fit we're gonna
pass train batches 10 epochs and we're
gonna need validation data and that'll
be test batches and we use something
like 20 of validation steps
ok so let's scroll down a little bit so
you can see it first of all and then
we're gonna think about once it's done
let's go ahead and plot it so let's may
as well do that now so let's handle that
so we want to convert our history to a
dictionary
and that's history dot history and we
want to get the accuracy by taking the
accuracy key and we want the validation
accuracy using correct syntax of course
Val accuracy for validation accuracy and
the number of epochs is just range one
to length of accuracy plus one so then
we want to do a plot big size nice and
large 12 by 9 we want to plot the epochs
versus the accuracy b0 label equals
training accuracy we want to plot the
validation accuracy using just a blue
line not blue O's or dots blue dot sorry
and label equals validation accuracy
plot dot X label each box plot dot y
label accuracy and let's go ahead and
add a title while we're at it
creating a validation accuracy roll down
a little bit we will include a legend
having extraordinarily difficult time
typing tonight location equals lower
right and a why limit of a 0.5 and one
that should be a tuple excuse me and
plot dot show alright so let's go ahead
to the terminal and run this and see
what the plot looks like and we are back
let me move my ugly mug over so we can
see a little bit more and let us run the
software and see what we get
ok so a started training and it takes
around 10 to 11 seconds per epoch so
it's gonna sit here and twiddle my
thumbs for a minute and fast forward the
video while we wait so of course once it
finished running I realize I have a typo
and that is typical so in line 46 it is
P it is I spelled out plot instead of P
LT but that's alright let's take a look
at the data we get in the terminal
anyway so you can see that the
validation accuracy it's around 90 2.5%
pretty good and the training accuracies
around 93 point a 2 so a little bit of
overtraining and I have run this a bunch
of times
and you tend to get a little bit more
we're training I'm kind of surprised at
this final now that I'm running over
YouTube it is actually a little bit less
overtraining but either way you know it
there are some evidence of overtraining
but a 90% accuracy for such a simple
model isn't entirely hateful so I'm
gonna go ahead and head back and correct
that typo and then run it again and then
show you the plot so it is here in line
46 right there and just make sure that
nothing else looks wonky and I believe
it is all good they're looking at my
cheat sheet everything looks fine ok
let's go back to the terminal and try it
again all right once more
all right so it has finished and you can
see that this time the validation
accuracy was around eighty nine point
five percent whereas the training
accuracy was ninety three point eight
five so it is a little bit over trainee
in this particular run and they're a
significant run to run variation as you
might expect so let's take a look at the
plot all right so I've stuck my ugly mug
right here in the middle so you can see
that the training accuracy goes up over
time as we would expect and the
validation accuracy generally does that
but kind of tops out about halfway
through the number of epochs so this is
clearly working and this is actually
pretty cool with such a simple model we
can get some decent review or sentiment
as it were classification but we can do
one more neat thing and that is to
actually visualize the relationships
between the words that are embedding
learns so let's head back to the code
editor and then let's write some code to
tackle that task okay so before we do
that you know I want to clean up the
code first let's go ahead and do that so
I will leave in all that commented stuff
but let's define a few functions we'll
need a function to get our data
we'll need a function to get our model
and we'll need a function to plot data
and we'll need a function to get our
embeddings will say retrieve
and beddings and i'll fill in the
parameters for those as we go along so
let's take this stuff from our get our
data cut that paste it and of course use
proper indentation because python is a
little bit particular about that okay
make sure everything lines up nicely and
then of course we have to return the
stuff that we are interested in so we
want to return train data test data and
in fact that's not actually what's going
to do I take it back let's come down
here and we want our sorry we don't
actually want to return our data bill
and turn our batches so return train
batches test batches and we'll also need
our encoder for the visualizing the
relationships relationships between
words so let's return that now
okay now let's handle the function for
the get model next so let's come down
here and grab this actually let's yeah I
grab all of it and come here and do that
and let's make embedding dim a parameter
of our model and you notice in our model
we need the encoder so we also have to
pass in the encoder as well as an
embedding dim and then at the bottom of
the function we want to return that
model pretty straightforward so then
let's handle the plot data next so we
have all of this grab that and indent
here so we're going to need a history
and that looks like all we need because
we define epochs accuracy and validation
accuracy okay so it looks like all we
need in the plot data function so then
we have to write our retrieve embeddings
function but first let's handle all the
other stuff we'll say train batches test
batches and encoder equals get data in
fact let's rename that to get batch data
to be more specific this is kind of
being pedantic but you always want to be
as per as descriptive as possible with
your naming conventions so that way
people can read the code and know
precisely what it does without having to
you know make any guesses so if I just
say get data it isn't necessarily clear
that I'm getting batches out of that
data you know I could just be getting
single instances it could return a
generator it is a little bit ambiguous
so changing the function name to get
batch data is the appropriate thing to
do so then let's say model equals get
model and we pass it the encoder and
then the history will work as intended
and then we call our function to plop
history and I should work as intended as
well and now we are ready to tackle the
retrieve embeddings function so that is
relatively straightforward so what we
want to do is we want to pass in the
model and the encoder and we don't want
to pass what we want to do is we want to
the purpose of this function is to take
our encoder and dump it to a TSV file
that we can load into a visualizer in
the browser to visualize the principal
component analysis of our word and
codings so we need files to write to and
we need to enumerate over the sub words
in our encoder and write the metadata as
well as the vectors for our encoding so
out vectors IO dot open
Beks TSV and in right mode and a coating
of utf-8 we need pout metadata and
that's similar meta TSV right encoding
equals UT have - 8 very similar now we
need to iterate over our encoder or sub
words and get the vectors on event to
dump to our vector file as well as the
metadata weights sub num +1 and so we
have the +1 here because remember that
we start from 1 because 0 is for our
padding right 0 doesn't correspond to a
word so the words start from 1 can go on
so we want to write the word plus a
newline and for the vectors that's right
a tab delimited string X in vector and
plus a newline character at the end and
then we want to close our files ok so
then we just scroll down and call our
function retrieve embeddings
model and encoder okay so assuming I
haven't made any typos this should
actually work so I'm gonna go ahead and
head back to the terminal and try it
again
all right moment of truth so it is
training so I didn't make any mistakes
up until that point 1 second we'll see
if it actually makes it through the plot
oh but really quick so if you run this
with tensorflow - let me move my face
out of the way if you run this with
tensorflow - you will get this out of
range end of sequence here
and if you do well if you do a google
search for that you will see a thread
about it in the github and basically
someone says that it is fixed in 2.10
Darcy won the version of tensorflow
which I am running however I still get
the warning on the first run in version
2.00 I get the warning on every epoch so
it kind of clutters up the terminal
output but it still runs nonetheless and
gets comprable accuracy so it doesn't
seem to affect the model performance but
it you know makes for an ugly YouTube
video and gives me uneasy feelings so I
went ahead and updated to the latest
release candidate to 1.0 and you can see
that it works relatively well so one
second and we'll see the plot again and
of course I made a mistake again its
plot history not its plot data and I'll
plot history let's fix that all right
plot let's change this to plot history
because that is more precise and we will
try it again let's do it all right so it
has finished and you can see that the
story is much the same a little bit of
what we're training on the training data
let's take a look at the plot and the
plot is totally consistent with what we
got the last time you know an increasing
training accuracy and a leveling off a
validation accuracy so let's go ahead
and check out how these word embeddings
look in the browser but first of course
I made a mistake so weights are not
defined and that is because I didn't
define them so let's go back to the code
editor and do that all right so what we
want to do is this weights equal model
dot layers sub 0 dot get weights
so this will give us the actual weights
from our model which is the the zero
player is the embedding layer and we
want to get the weights and the zeroth
element of that so I'm gonna go ahead
and head back to the terminal and I'm
gonna actually get rid of the plot here
because we know that works and I'm sick
of seeing it so we will just do the
model fitting and retrieve the embedding
so let's do that now so one of the
downsides of doing code live is I make
all kinds of silly mistakes while
talking and typing but that's life
see in a minute all right so that
finished running let's head to the
browser and take a look at what it looks
like okay so can i zoom in I can a
little bit so let's take a look at this
so to get this you go to load over here
on the Left sign you can't really see my
cursor but you go to load on the left
side load your vector and metadata files
and then you want to click on this three
labels mode here and let's take a look
at this so you see right here on the
left side a next seated and ottoman so
these would make sense to be you know
pretty close together because they you
know kind of would you would expect
those three words to be together right
annex and ceeded if you annex something
someone else has to cede it it makes
sense let's kind of move around a little
bit see what else we can find
okay so this looks like a good one we
see waterways navigable human rainfall
petroleum earthquake so you can see
there are some pretty good relationships
here between the words that all makes
sense if you scroll over here what's
interesting as you see Estonia herzog
Ivania Slovakia sorry for mispronouncing
that Cyprus you see a bunch of country
names so it seems to learn the names it
seems to learn that there are
relationships between different
geographic regions in this case
countries there we see seeded and
annexed on Ottoman again and you can
even see Concord in here next to annexed
and seeded deposed ark Bishop Bishop
assassinated oh he can't see that
my face there just moved me over so now
you can see surrendered conquered Spain
right Spain was conquered for a time by
the Moors Archbishop deposed surrendered
assassinated invaded you can see all
kinds of cool stuff here so this is what
it looks like I've seen other words like
beautiful wonderful together other stuff
so if you play around this you'll see
all sorts of interesting relationships
between words and this is just the
visual representation of what the word
embeddings look like in a reduced
dimensional representation of its higher
dimensional space so I hope that has
been helpful I thought this was a really
cool project just a few dozen lines of
code and you get to something that is
actually a really neat kind of a neat
result where you have a higher
dimensional space that gives you
mathematic relationships between words
and it does a pretty good job of
learning the relationships between those
words and now what's interesting is I
wonder how well this can be generalized
to other stuff so if we feed it you know
say twitter Twitter tweets could we get
the sentiment out of that I'm not
entirely sure that's something we would
have to play around with it seems like
you would be able to so long as there a
significant overlap in the dictionaries
between the words that we have for the
IMDB reviews and the dictionary words
from the Twitter feeds that we scrape
but that would be an interesting
application of this to kind of find
toxic Twitter comments and the like but
I hope this was helpful just a reminder
my new course is on sale for $9.99 for
the next 5 days there'll be one more
sale last several days of the year but
there will be a gap of several days in
between this channel totally supported
by and revenue as well as my core sales
so if you want to support the cause go
ahead and click the link in the pinned
comment slash description and if not hey
go ahead and share this because that is
totally free and I like that just as
well leave a comment down below hit the
subscribe button if you haven't already
hit the bell icon to get notified when I
release new content and I will see you
in the next video
in this tutorial you are gonna learn how
to do it send them a classification with
tensorflow
2.0 let's get started
before we begin a couple of notes first
of all it would be very helpful if you
have already seen my previous video on
doing word embeddings in tensorflow 2.0
because we're gonna be borrowing heavily
from the concepts I presented in that
video if not it's not a huge deal I'll
show you everything we need to do as we
go along it's just it'll make more sense
with that sort of background second
point is that I am working through the
official tensor flow tutorials this
isn't my code I did have to fix a couple
of bugs in the code so I guess that
makes it mine to some extent but
nonetheless I did not write this so I'm
just presenting it for your consumption
in video format all that said let's go
ahead and get to coding our sentiment
analysis software
so as usual we begin with our imports we
will need the tensor flow datasets to
handle the data from the IMDB library of
course you need tensor flow to handle
tensor flow type operations so the first
thing we want to do is to load our data
set and get our training and testing
data from that as well as our encoder
which I explained in the previous video
so let's start there data set and info
is load of the IMDB views help if I
spelled it correctly sub words 8k now
just a word these are the reviews a
bunch of reviews from the IMDB data set
so you have a review with an Associated
classification of either positive or
negative with info he goes true as
supervised equal to true tab that over
next we will need our training and
testing data sets
set equals a dataset sub train and data
set sub tests and finally we need part
encoder dot encoder good grief I can
type cannot type tonight at all so if
you don't know what an encoder is the
basic idea is that it is a sort of
reduced dimensional representation of a
set of words so you take a word and it
associates that with an N dimensional
vector that has components that will be
non perpendicular to other words in your
dictionary so what that means is that
you can express words in terms of each
other whereas if you set each word in
your dictionary to be a basis vector
they are orthogonal and so there's no
relationship between something like king
and queen for instance whereas with the
auto encoder representation whereas with
the sorry the weird embedding
representation it is the it has a
nonzero component of one vector along
another so you have some relationship
between words that allows you to parse
meaning of your string of text and I
give a better explanation in my previous
video so check that out for your own
education so we're going to need a
couple of global variables and buffer
size 10,000 a batch size for training
and some padded shapes and this is for
padding so when you have a string of
words the string of words could be
different lengths so you have to pad to
the length of the longest review
basically and that is batch size by
empty
so the next thing we'll need is our
actual data set we're going to shuffle
it because we are good data scientists
and we're gonna want to get a padded
batch from that in the shape defined
with the variable above and the test
data set is very similar
good grief so Ivan I'm using them for my
new text editor part of my new year's
resolution and let's yank that and it is
a little bit tricky if you've never used
it before I'm still getting used to it
there we go as you can see then we have
to go back into insert mode test data
set test data set dot padded bench and
padded shapes all right that is good
next thing we need is our models so the
model is going to be a sequential Karras
model with a bi-directional layer as
well as a couple of dense layers we use
a binary cross interview loss with an
atom optimizer learning rate of 10 by 1
by 10 to the minus 4 and then we will
say TF Karis layers and bedding and
kotor vocab the size 64 TF care us
players bidirectional TF Karis layers LS
TM 64 to parentheses
dents and that is 64 with a Lu
activation if I could ever learn to type
properly that would be very helpful
another Bend Slayer with an output and
this output is going to get a sigmoid
activation and what this represents is
the probability of the review being
either positive or negative so the final
output of the model is going to be a
floating-point number between 0 and 1
and it will be the probability of it
being a positive review and we're gonna
pass in a couple of dummy reviews just
some kind of softball kind of stuff to
see how well it does but before that we
have to compile our model and with a
binary cross-entropy loss optimizer
equals TF Kerris optimizers and I'm
learning rated 1 by 10 to the minus 4
and we want metrics accuracy and then we
want the history which is just the model
fit and this is really for plotting
purposes but I'm not gonna do any
plotting you get the idea that the you
know the accuracy goes up over the time
and and the loss goes down over time so
no real need to plot that train data set
we're just gonna do three epochs you can
do more but for the purposes of the
video I'm just going to do three I just
do five because I'll do five for the
next model we're gonna do validation
data equals test data set and validation
steps 30
so next we need to consider a couple of
functions so one of them is to pad the
the vectors that we pass in to whatever
size and the second is to actually
generate a prediction so let's define
this functions and just to be clear this
is for the sample text we're going to
pass him because remember the reviews
all are all of varying lengths and so we
have to for purposes of the I guess you
could say continuity of inputs to your
model and not a really technical phrase
but so that way you pass in the same
length of vector to you know your model
for the training we have to deal with a
problem of the same problem with the
sample text so we're gonna pass in
because we don't have an automated
tensorflow function to handle it for us
and we're gonna Pat it with zeros
because those don't have any meaning in
our dictionary and we want to return the
vector after extending it so if you're
not familiar with this idiom in Python
you can multiply a quantity like say a
string by a number to basically multiply
that string so if you had the letter A
multiplied by 10 it would give you 10 s
and you can do that with you know list
elements as well pretty cool stuff
neat little feature of Python little
known I think but that's what we're
doing here so we're gonna going to pad
the zeros to the size of whatever
whatever size we want - whatever the
length of our vector is and extend that
vector with those zeros next we need a
sample predict function and the reason
we can't just do model dot predict is
because we had the the issue of dealing
with the padding
text equals encode or got encode and
remember the encoder is what goes from
the string representation to the higher
dimensional representation that allows
you to make correlations between words
so if you want to Pat it then pad to
size encoded sample bread text 64 that's
our batch size or our max length sorry
and then encoded sample bread text was
TF cast 32 and predictions model that
predict you have that expand dimensions
encoded sample bread text 0 batch
dimension return the predictions all
right so now we have a model that we
have trained once you run the code of
course now let's come up with a couple
of dummy simple very basic reviews to
see how it scores them so we'll say
sample text equals this movie was
awesome acting was incredible highly
recommend then we're gonna spell sample
text correctly of course and then we're
going to come up with our predictions
ego sample predict sample text pad
equals true and we're gonna multiply
that by 100 so we get it as a percentage
and can i I can't quite scroll down that
is a feature not a bug I am sure you can
write in whatever positive review you
want
so then we'll say print probability
this is a positive review predictions
and I haven't done this before so when I
coded this up the first time I have it
executing twice once with pat equals
false once with pat equals true to see
the Delta in the predictions and
surprise surprise is more accurate when
you give it a padded reviews but in this
case I'm gonna change it up on the fly
and do a different set of sample text
and give it a negative review and see
how it does
this movie was soso I don't know what
this is gonna do that's kind of a you
know vernacular I don't that is in the
database so we'll see the acting was
mediocre kind of recommend and
predictions sample predict sample and
text Pat equals true times 100 and we
can yank the line and paste it alright
okay so we're gonna go ahead and save
this and go back to the terminal and
execute it and see how it does and then
we're gonna come back and write a
slightly more complicated model to see
how well that does to see if you know
adding complexity to the model improves
the accuracy of our predictions so let
us write quit and if you've never used
vim you have to press : WQ sorry when
you're not in insert mode right quit to
get help and then we're gonna go to the
terminal and see how well it does
alright so here we are in the terminal
let's give it a shot and see how many
typos I made ooh interesting so it says
check that the data set name is spelled
correctly that probably means I
misspelled the name of the data set all
right let me scroll up a little bit
it's IMDB reviews okay I am alright
their dataset
yeah you can't yeah right there okay so
I misspelled the name of the dataset not
a problem
then TF sentiment let us go up to here
I am DB right quit and give it another
shot I misspelled dents okay can you see
that no not quite
it says here let me move myself over has
no attribute dents so let's fix that
that's in line 24 124 insert an S quit
and try again there now it is training
for five eat box I am gonna let this
ride and show you the results when it is
done really quick you can see that it
gives this funny error let me go ahead
and move my face out of the way now this
I keep seeing in the tensorflow two
steps so as far as I can tell this is
related to the version of tensor flow
this isn't something I'm doing or you're
doing there is an open issue on github
and previously it would run that error
every time I trained with every epoch
however after updating I do I think
tensorflow 2.1 it only does after the
first one so I guess you gain a little
bit there but it is definitely but it's
definitely an issue with tensor flows so
I'm not too worried about that so let's
go ahead on this train alright so it has
finished running and I have teleported
to the top right so you can see the
accuracy and you can see accuracy starts
out low and
up around 93.9% not too shabby for just
five epochs on a very simple model like
why is the lost arts relatively high and
goes relatively low what's most
interesting is that we do get a seventy
nine point eight percent probability
that our first review was positive which
it is so an 80% probability of it being
correct is pretty good and then an only
41 point 9 3 percent probability the
second being positive now this was a bit
of a lukewarm review I said it was so so
so a 40% probability of it being
positive is pretty reasonable in my
estimation so now let's see if we can
make a more complex model and get better
results so let's go back to the code and
type that up so here we are let's scroll
down and say let's make our new model so
model you have to make sure you're an
insert mode of course model equals TF
Harris sequential TF Kerris layers of
course you need an embedding layer to
start encoder vocab the size 64 let's
move my mug like so and at our next
layer which is Karis layers
bi-directional LST m64 returned true and
I am way too far over 88 that is still
well we're just gonna have to live with
it it's just gonna be bad code not up to
the Pepe standards but whatever Sumi
bi-directional ell stm32
caris layers dot dense and 64 with a
value activation and to prevent
overfitting we are going to add in a
little bit of drop out just 0.5 so 50%
and add our final classification layer
with a sigmoid activation model do I
have I'm a double check here looks like
I forgot a friend to see there we go
good grief
delete that line and make our new model
a lot compile loss equals binary cross
entropy optimizer equals atom same
learning rate we don't want to change
too many things at once that wouldn't be
scientific accuracy mystery equals model
that fit train data set data sets not
cert epochs equal 5 validation data sets
equals test data set 30 validation steps
and we're just going to scroll up here
and copy whoop copy all of this visual
yank and come down and paste all right
so aha
what's so I'm detecting a problem here
so I need to modify my sample predict a
problem my sample predict so let's go
ahead and pass in a model call it model
underscore just to be safe because I'm
declaring one model and then another
want to make sure these scoping issues
are not going to bite me in the rear end
I need model equals model and let's do
likewise here well if you goes model and
we'll come up here and modify it here as
well just to be pedantic and I'm very
tired so this is probably unnecessary
but we want to make sure we aren't
getting any funny scoping issues so that
the model is doing precisely what we
would expect so let's go ahead and write
quit and try running it oh actually I
take it back I want to go ahead and get
rid of the fitting for this because
we've already run it now we can leave it
actually you know what now that I'm
thinking about it let's just do this
and then we will comment this out all
right and then we don't even need the
the model equals model there but I'm
gonna leave it all right let's try it
again let's see what we get so remember
we had a eighty percent and forty one
percent or forty two percent probability
of it being positive so let's see what
we get with the new model validation and
data set so I must have missed typed
something so let's take a look here
right there and because it is validation
data not validation data set all right
try it again all right it is training I
will let this run and show you the
results when it finishes so of course
after running it I realize I made a
mistake in the in the Declaration of the
sample predict function
typical typical unexpected keyword
argument so let's come here and you know
let's just get rid of it
oh cuz it's model underscore yeah let's
get rid of it because we no longer need
it and get rid of this typical typical
all right this is one of the situations
in which a jupiter notebook would be
helpful but whatever I will stick to
them and the terminal and PI files
because I'm hold alright let's try this
again and I'll just go ahead and edit
all this out and we will meet up when it
finishes I've done it again it's not my
day
folks not my day and let us find that
there delete once again all right so I
finally fixed all the errors it is done
training and we have our results so
probability this is a positive review
86% a pretty good improvement over 80%
what's even better is that the
probability of the second review which
was lukewarm so so being positive has
fallen from 41 or 42 percent down to 20
22 % almost cut in half so pretty good
improvement with a they you know
somewhat more complicated model and at
the expense of slightly longer training
so you know 87 seconds as opposed to 47
seconds so I know some ties 6 minutes as
opposed to three not too bad so anyway
so what we've done here is loaded a
series of IMDB reviews used it to train
a model to do sentiment prediction by
looking at correlations between the
words and the labels for either positive
or negative sentiment and then asking
the model to predict what the sentiment
of a obviously positive and somewhat
lukewarm review was and we get pretty
good results in a very short amount of
time that is the power of tensorflow 2.0
so I thank you for watching any
questions comments leave them down below
I try to answer all of them less so now
that I have more subscribers more views
it gets a little bit more overwhelming
but I will do my best
speaking of which hit the subscribe
button hit the notification bell because
I know
only 14% of you are getting my
notifications and look forward to seeing
you in the next video where he sees your
head my lovely we sleep her with my hate
or for me think that we give his cruel
he cries said your honor's ear I shall
grow moss no I haven't just had a stroke
don't call 9-1-1 I've just written a
basic artificial intelligence to
generate Shakespearean text now we get
to finally address the question which is
better writing Shakespearean sonnets a
billion monkey hours or a poorly trained
AI let's get started
alright first before we begin with our
imports a couple of administrative notes
the first of which is that this is an
official tensorflow tutorial I have not
written this code myself and in fact it
is quite well written as it is the first
tutorial I haven't had to make any
Corrections or adjustments to so I will
leave a link in the description for
those that want to go into this in more
detail on their own time so feel free to
check that out when you have a moment
available let's get started with our
imports the first thing one import is os
that will handle some operation os-level
type stuff we want tensorflow
as TF of course I only want numpy as NP
now notably we are not importing the
tensorflow data set imports because this
is not using an official tensorflow data
set rather it is using the data due to I
believe Andrey Carpathia gets a credit
for this but it is basically a text
representation of a Shakespearean sonnet
which one I don't know it doesn't state
in the tutorial and I am NOT well-read
enough to be able to identify it based
on the first several characters I
suppose if I printed out another to the
terminal I couldn't figure it out based
on who's in it but I don't know and it's
not really all that important but what
is important is that we have to download
it using the built-in tensorflow chaos
utils and of course they have their own
function to get a file and it's just a
simple text file called Shakespeare text
and that lives at HTTP storage google
api's comm Shakespeare dot txt
okay and so let's get an idea for what
we're working with here so let's open it
up in read binary mode with an encoding
of utf-8 and let's go ahead and print
out the length of the text
so we'll say length of the text blank
characters dot format when text and
let's go ahead and print the first 250
characters to get an idea of what we are
working with all right let's head to the
terminal and test this out say python TF
text Gen dot PI object has no attribute
decode so I have messed something up
most likely a parenthesis somewhere text
equals open path to file dot read that's
right I forgot the read method
insert read dot decode there we go let's
try that perfect so now we see that we
do indeed have some text and it has 1
million 115,000 394 characters so a
fairly lengthy work you know several
hundred thousand words at least and you
see begins with first is it first
citizen this is important because we're
gonna refer back to this text a few
different times in the tutorial so just
keep in mind that the first word is
first very very simple and hey if you
know what play or sonnet this is leave a
comment down below because you're you
know more well cultured more well-read
than I am I would be interested to know
but let's proceed to the tutorial its
head back to our file and the first
thing we want to do is comment these out
because we don't want to print that to
the terminal every single time we run
the code but the first thing we have the
handle is vectorizing our text now if
you haven't seen my other two tutorials
on natural language processing and
tensorflow
you
we have to go from a text-based
representation to an integer
representation or in some cases yet
totally energy representation not
floating-point in order to pass this
data into the deep neural network so
let's go ahead and start with that so we
say our vocabulary is going to be sorted
a set of the text so we're just going to
sort it and make a set of unique stuff
so we'll say print or unique words
rather blank unique characters format
blend of vocab
so we now important thing to keep in
mind is that we are starting with merely
characters we are not starting with any
conception of a word so the model is
gonna go from knowing nothing about
language at all to understanding the
concept of words as well as line breaks
and a little bit about grammar you kind
of saw from the introduction that it's
not so great probably better than the
monkeys typing away but it is you know
starting from cleat scratch into
something that kind of approximates
language processing so we have sorted
our vocabulary now we have to go from
the character space to the integer
representation so we'll say care to IDX
where care is just you know character
that's going to be dictionary of unique
characters and their integer ID X their
integer encoding for ID X unique in
enumerate vocab a closing bracket and we
need the ID X to care which is the
inverse operation numpy array of vocab
then we have something called text as
int and that's an umpire array of a list
comprehension of caret to IDX of care
for care in text so we're just going to
take all the characters in the text look
up their ID X representation and stick
it into a vector numpy array in this
case
so now let's go ahead and print this
stuff out to see what we're dealing with
to see what our vocabulary looks like
and we'll make something pretty looking
we'll say for care blank and zip care to
IDX range 20 we're only going to look at
the first 20 elements we don't need to
print out the whole dictionary print for
s :
3d got format representation of the
character care to IDX care and then at
the end we'll print a new line I
shouldn't do this too so we'll say print
blank characters Matt - int you know how
many characters they'll be mapped to int
the format representation of text just
the first 13 text has int 13 to add that
over and write this and run it as you
unexpected end of file while parsing
okay so what that means is I have
forgotten a parentheses which is here
perfect now we can write quit now let's
give it a shot
okay so you can see we have 65 unique
characters so we have a dictionary of 65
characters and newline maps to 0 space
maps to 1 so basically it's the sort has
placed all of the characters the non non
alphanumeric characters at the beginning
and we even have some numbers in there
curiously the number 3 maps to 9 but
whatever and then you see we have the
capital letters and the lowercase
letters will follow later and so our
first sentence is first citizen first 13
characters rather and that map's to this
following a vector here so we have gone
from this string to this and vector
representation so that is all well and
good but that is just the first step in
the process so the next step is handling
what we call the prediction problem so
the real goal here is to feed the models
some string of text and then it outputs
the most likely characters it thinks
will follow based on what it reads in
the Shakespearean work and so we want to
chunk up our data into sequences of
length 100 and then go ahead and use
that to create a data set and then from
there we can create batches of data in
other words chunks of sentences or
chunks of whatever sequence like the
characters we want let's go ahead and go
back to our event editor and start there
and so the first thing is we want to go
ahead and comment all this out because
we don't want to print everything every
single time and then handle the problem
of the sequence length so we'll say
sequence lines equals 100 characters
something manageable you want some into
smalls them into large so number of
examples per epic PETA's line of text /
sequence a length plus 1 where does a
plus 1 come from it comes from the fact
that we're going to be feeding it a
character and trying to predict the rest
of the characters in the sequence so you
have the plus 1 there next we have a
care data set TF data data set of course
it's tensorflow it has to deal with its
own data sets it doesn't handle text
files too well so we're going to go data
set from tensor slices text as int let's
go ahead and print out what we have here
for I in care data set dot take the
first five elements and so this is just
a sequence of individual characters so
we should get the first five characters
out print hi DX to care hi numpy let's
go ahead and go to the terminal and run
this right quit
and run it once more and you see we get
the word first as one would expect that
is the we scroll up that is the first
five characters first and then citizen
okay so that seems to work
so now let's handle batching the data so
let's go back to our vim editor get rid
of this print statement by inserting a
couple of comments and worry about
dealing with a batch so sequence says
equals care and dataset top badge
steepens length plus one drop remainder
equals true so we just get rid of the
characters at the end for item can I
scroll down at all does it let me do
that no it does not one of the downsides
of vim as an editor so for item in
sequence is take five the first five
sequences of 100 characters print
representation blank join idx to care
item number I and a whole bunch of
parentheses and let's go ahead and go
back to the terminal and see how this
runs so let's run it and you see I
really should put a new line in there at
the beginning we can see for a citizen
before we proceed any further here me
speak blah blah blah so we get a bunch
of character sequences including the
newline characters so that is pretty
helpful so one thing to note is that
these new lines are what give the the
deep neural network a sense of where
line breaks occur so it knows that after
some sequence of characters they should
expect the line break because that
formulates you know the kind of metered
speaking that you find in Shakespeare so
that's well and good let's go ahead and
handle the next problem of splitting our
data into chunks of target and input
text remember we have to start with one
character and predict the next set of
characters so let's handle that
but of course to begin we want to
comment that out and in fact we do we
need this now let's leave it in there
it's not going to hurt anything so we'll
say we're gonna define a function called
split input target and that takes a
chunk of data as input and it says input
text he goes chunk everything up to
minus one target text egos chunk one
onward return input text target text so
we're going to get an input sequence as
well as a target so we want to double
set how we want to double check this by
saying data set equal sequences dot map
on a map dysfunction on to our sequences
split input target to add in a new line
for clarity and say you know let's do
this there we go
so we'll say we're gonna print the first
examples of the input and target values
say for input example target example in
dataset take just the first thing print
input data representation blank join idx
to care inputs example dot numpy whole
bunch of parentheses print target data
representation blank join idx to care
target example numpy alright let's head
to the terminal and try this
okay so you see our input data is this
for a citizen before we proceed any
further and it ends with you and then
the target data is earth citizen
so given this input what is the target
so we have basically shifted the data
one character to the right for our
target with respect to our input and
that's a task given one character
predict the next likely sequence of
characters so to make that more clear
let's go ahead and kind of step through
that one character at a time so let's
come down here and of course the first
thing we want to do is get rid of these
print statements and then say for I
input ID X target ID X in the numerator
input example first five target example
I forgot a zip statement 5 how many
that's the enumerate that gets a colon I
forgot my zip here in a numerate zip I
had an extra parentheses and then we
want to add a print statement I will say
print step four d dot format I print
blank input some string format input ID
X representation of ID x to care and put
a DX
prynt expected output yes dot dot format
target PI DX comma representation I'd X
to care target ID X alright now let's
head to the terminal and run this and we
should get something that makes perfect
sense the input example is not defined
okay so input example oh of course I got
rid of this alright alright so here you
can see the output so step 0 the input
is an integer 18 that maps to the
character F and the expected output is I
so it knows that it should expect the
next character which is the next
character in this evening I'll keep in
mind this isn't trained with an RNN yet
this is just stepping through the data
to kind of show you that given one
character what should it expect next so
that's all well and good next thing we
have to handle is creating training
batches and then training our model
building and training the model so let's
head back to the text editor and handle
that so let's go ahead and comment all
this out and handle the conception of a
batch so we'll say
let's handle the batch size next we'll
say badge
size equals 64 and buffer size just how
many characters you unload 10,000
dataset ego state asset shuffle buffer
size that batch batch size drop
remainder heels true then we want to say
vocab the size you goes learn a vocab
we're gonna start building our model
next so embedding dimension 256 Arne in
units 1024 so we will use a function to
go ahead and build our model we'll say
def build model vocab the size embedding
dim RNN units batch size model TF Kerris
sequential TF Kerris layers an embedding
layer of course we have to go with an
embedding layer at the beginning because
if you recall from the first video we
had to go from this integer
representation to a reduce dimensional
representation a word embedding that
allows the model to find relationships
between words because this integer basis
all of these vectors are orthogonal to
one another there's no overlap of
characters however in the word embedding
the higher dimensional space or reduced
dimensional space allows you to have
some overlap of relationship between
characters so those vectors are not
orthogonal they are to some extent
collinear so just a bit of math speak
for you but that is what is going on
there
vocab size embedding dim the batch you
can put shape equals batch size by none
so it can take something arbitrary and
and that next layer T of Karass layers a
gated recurrent unit a type of R and n
that is R and n units return sequences
equals true stateful equals true
recurrent initializer initializer I
think I spelled that right glow rot
uniform is that right yep
okay so now we have another layer let's
tab that over say T of Karis out layers
dense and a lot with something of a
vocab sighs so now let's and that and
return our model so now that we have a
model the next thing we want to do is
build and compile that model so we'll
save model those build model vocab size
equals one out vocab you know this is
one I guess one kind of thing I don't
like about the tutorial
embedding din there's a little bit of
that little bit right there but whatever
betting dim and we need aren't in units
equals RNN units badge size equals batch
size so that will make our model and
let's go ahead and see what type of
predictions that model outputs without
training so we'll say for input example
batch target example batch and data set
take one I'll keep in mind this is going
to be quite rough because there is no
you know there's no training yet so it's
gonna be garbage but let's just see what
we get so they say example batch
predictions he does model input example
batch print example let's print the
shape example batch shape and I should
be batch size sequence length
and vocab sighs and you know what while
we're at it let's just print out a model
summary so you can see what's going on
and see what is what so let's head to
the terminal try this again see how many
typos I made batch inputs shape that's
probably a batch input shape on line 77
right here batch size batch size what
have I done something stupid and no
doubt oh it's probably here batch inputs
shape there we go
try it again okay so you can see that it
it has outputs of something batch size
by hundred characters by boat capsized
makes sense here is the model four
million or so parameters they're all
trainable and you can see that the
majority of those are in the gated
recurrent unit so let's go back to the
text editor and start thinking about
it's not thinking about training the
model so we come here let's go ahead and
get rid of this print statement but you
don't need it we can get rid of the
model summary as well and think about
training our model the first thing we
need to train the model is a loss of
function so we'll pass in labels and log
its and return TF care s losses sparse
categorical cross-entropy
labels log it's from log it's equals
true and then since we are good python
programmers we will format this a little
bit better
like that and we can go ahead and start
training our model so we will say so we
will say a model compile and optimizer
equals Adam loss equals loss and say
checkpoint directory equals dot slash
training checkpoints Check Point prefix
use LS path join checkpoint der check
yeah checkpoint underscore epoch so
epoch is a variable it's gonna get
passed in by tensorflow
or care us in this case and so it'll
know whatever you know epoch Ron will
save a checkpoint with that name
checkpoint call back you have to define
call backs TF Karis called backstop
model checkpoint file path Eagles
checkpoint prefix save weights only
equals true and so we'll train for in
this case I don't know something like
for reference I trained it for a hundred
eight box to generate the text you saw
at the beginning of the tutorial but it
doesn't really matter all that much so
we'll say 25 epochs because it's not the
most sophisticated model in the world
so we'll say history equals model dot
fit data set epoch sequels epochs
callbacks equals checkpoint call back
alright let's head to the terminal and
run this
it says expected string bytes not a
tuple oh okay
so as paths join that I've probably made
some kind of silly mistake
it says checkpoint Durr
that is a string checkpoint underscore
epoch is fine that's interesting now
what was that error that is on line 91
oh I understand so I have a comma there
at the end so it's an implied tuple okay
let's try this again
scratching my head trying to figure that
one out all right so now it is training
so I'm gonna go ahead and let this run
and I will be back when it is finished
okay so it has finished training and you
can see that the loss went down by a
factor of you know three or four about
three or so from two point seven all the
way down to 0.77 so it did pretty well
in terms of training now this is 25
epochs we don't have to rerun the
training because we did the model
checkpointing so the next and final
order of business is to write the
function to generate the predictive text
you know the output of the model so that
way we can kind of get some sort of idea
of what sort of Shakespearean prose this
artificial intelligence can generate
let's go ahead and head to our file so
the first thing we have to think about
is how are we going to handle loading
our model and that will require that we
don't do the build model up here so we
can just get rid of that and we
certainly don't want to compile or train
the model again we want to load it from
a check point so what we'll do is say
model goes build model
oh cab sighs embedding dim RNN units and
batch size equals what batch size equals
one that's right because when we pass in
a set of input text we don't want to get
out you know a huge batch of output text
we just want a single sequence of output
text let me see a model dot load weights
T of that train latest checkpoint
checkpoint der so this will scan the
directory and get our load as checkpoint
latest checkpoint and then we want to
build the model by saying T of tensor
shape one by none so back size of one
and an arbitrary length of characters so
then we'll say model dot summary and we
can scroll down a little bit for
readability
so that'll print out the new model to
the terminal so the next thing we have
to handle is the prediction of the
prediction problem of generating text so
let's say define generate text model and
start string so we need to pass in the
model we want to use to generate the
text as well as a starting string a
prompt for the AI if you will
I'm generate equals 1000 that's the
number of characters we want to generate
input eval equals care to IDX s for s
and start string we have to go to the
character representation of sorry the
integer representation of our characters
and then we have to expand that along
the batch dimension we need an empty
list to keep track of our generated text
and a temperature so the temperature
kind of handles theme so the temperature
kind of handles the surprising factor of
the text so it'll take the text and
scale up by some number in this case a
temperature one means just whatever they
model output so a smaller number means
more more reasonable more predictable
text and larger number gives you
some kind of crazy wacky type of stuff
so let us reset states on our model and
say where I scroll down I in range Nam
generates predictions equals model
inputs eval predictions equals T up
squeeze along the batch dimension 0
predictions equals predictions divided
by temperature and predicted ID which is
the the prediction of the ID of the word
returned by the model TF random
categorical predictions nom samples
equals 1 minus 1 0 dot number pi then we
say input eval equals TF that expand
dims predicted PI D 0 text generated dot
append ID x2 care predicted ID so if
you're not familiar with this the random
category was a probability distribution
when you have a set of discrete
categories and it will predict them I
forgot a 1 here that will break so it
will it will generate predictions
according to the distribution defined by
this variable predictions so then we
want to return start string and that may
be familiar to you if you watch some of
my other reinforcement learning
tutorials the actor critic methods in
particular use the categorical
distribution plus and B string that join
text generated
so then you want to say print generate
text model start string equals Romeo :
give it a space as well all right now
moment of truth let's see how well our
model does write that go to the terminal
and try it again so you see it loads the
model pretty well and we have our text
that is quite quick
so King Richard the third says I will
practice on his son you are be heads for
me you Henry Brutus replies and welcome
general and music the while Tyrell you
know I'm wondering if these aren't the
collected works of Shakespeare actually
now that I'm reading this looking at all
of the names that's kind of Brutus and
King Richard that sounds like it's from
a couple of different plays Caesar and
whatever King Richard appears and I
don't know again I'm an uncultured swine
you let me know but you can see that
what's really fascinating here is that
this model started out with no
information about the English language
whatsoever it knew nothing at all about
English we didn't tell it that there are
words we didn't tell there are sentences
we didn't tell it that you should add in
breaks or periods or any other type of
punctuation it knows nothing at all and
within I don't know two and a half
minutes of training it generates a model
that can string together characters and
words in a way that almost kind of makes
sense now you know Bernadine says I am a
Roman and by tenet and me now that is
mostly gibber ish but I am a Roman
certainly makes sense you know but
warwick i poison that you have heard you
know that is kind of something to add my
own important process of that hung in
point okay that's kind of silly is is
pointing that my soul I love him well so
it strings together words in a way that
almost makes sense now returning back to
the question of which is better a
billion monkey hours of typing or this
AI my money's solidly on the AI you know
these aren't put together randomly these
are put together probabilistically and
they kind of sort of make sense
and you can see how more sophisticated
models like the
open a text generator could be somewhat
more sophisticated using transformer
networks and how they can be better at
actually creating text that even makes
even more sense although what's
interesting is that it's not you know a
significant quote/unquote quantum leap I
hate that phrase but it's not a quantum
leap over what we've done here in just a
few minutes on our own GPU in our own
rooms that is quite cool and that is
something that never ceases to amaze me
so I hope you found this tutorial
enjoyable if you have make sure to hit
the subscribe and the bell icon because
I know only 14% of you get my
notifications we look forward to seeing
you all in the next video